GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE MEETING FOR MONDAY
MARCH ELEVENTH IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER -- FEATURED BUT AS AN
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS FEMALE
HAS ALSO BEEN TELEVISED AB
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PULLING HERE CUNNINGHAM YOUR
AREA HERE FLORA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE IN TRYING
MATHIS YOUR PARKS OVER HERE
FROM US HERE RATE US WICKS
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE
A CONSENT AGENDA OUR MOTION
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA SECOND
MOVERS -- CARILLO SECONDED BY
MISTER MATHIS -- BETTER SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
HI COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM FIVE
SEVEN AM I CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA FLORA I AGREE
SENATE KAMLAGER-DOVE YEAH
KAMLAGER-DOVE I AM MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MATHIS AYE AYE
QUIRK SILVA AYE BURKE SO FAR
I RAMOS FROM MOST AYE REAVIS
WORKS WEBSITE MISSION SOURCES
PASSED AND THIS RULES QUINCY
JONES THANK YOU VERY MUCH